okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about scientific notation something you
definitely want to know for the act so
let's just kind of go over this real
quick so scientific notation is when you
write a really large number or a really
small number in a compact form usually
with a 10 to a power so the idea is you
want just one digit a single digit
between 1 and 9 okay in front of the
decimal point and then the remainder of
the significant digits after the decimal
point and then raised to 10 to the power
okay so an example would be like say you
had three million eight hundred thousand
right now the decimal points right here
we wanna move it to right there so we
just have the three just one digit in
front of the decimal point so we have to
move it one two three four five six
places so that's 3.8
times 10 to the sixth so when you see
this positive exponent here that tells
you to move the decimal six places to
the right 10 to the sixth is uh
a million right so basically that's 3.8
times a million and you're moving that
to the right now this is a really small
number here we want that decimal point
to end up right there so that we just
have one
single digit okay between one and nine
in front of the decimal point so we're
going to be moving this one two three
four five six seven places so that's
going to be 5.73
times 10 to the negative seventh okay
the negative tells us that when you see
a number like this is very small and you
would be moving this decimal point seven
places to the left
now when you work with scientific
numbers if you're multiplying or
dividing for example when you multiply
you'd multiply these numbers here in
front so 3 times 5 is 15
and then you'd multiply the power of
tens so 10 squared times 10 cubed is 10
to the fifth because remember when you
multiply and you have the same base
you're adding the exponents right
but when you look at this number it's
really not in scientific notation
because you see the decimal points right
there so we have to move it one place to
the left that's making it smaller by a
power of 10. we have to counterbalance
that by adding 1
to the power of 10 here so that we don't
change the overall value of the number
so this is actually 1.5 times 10 to the
sixth power
okay now this one we're dividing we're
going to divide these two numbers 4
divided by 2 is 2
and then 10 to the 8th okay divided by
10 to the first when you divide you
subtract the exponent so that's 10 to
the 7th this one is already in
scientific notation it's just 2.0 times
10 to the 7th okay let's look at a
typical example here so see if you can
do this one on your own and then you
know go ahead we'll uh go through it
together so if a spaceship can travel
8.0 times 10 to the 8th meters per
second and if it wants to travel 4 times
10 to the 20th meters how long will it
take to arrive in seconds
okay so see if you can do that on your
own
so the way we would do this is you would
take the distance okay which is 4 times
10 to the 20th okay meters divided by
the time which is
i'm sorry by the speed which is eight
point zero times ten to the eighth
meters per second
and you can see here four divided by
eight gives us
one half which is 0.5 and then 10 to the
20th divided by 10 to the eighth that's
going to be 10 to the 12th because we're
subtracting and then this is going to be
seconds but we want to convert this into
a scientific number by moving this
decimal point so now that it's 5.0 we
made this number larger when you move
the decimal point to the right so to
counter balance that we're gonna have to
subtract one
from the exponent there and make this
ten to the eleventh seconds now the way
i did this problem is you know the
formula distance equals rate times time
right
so basically we're trying to solve for
the the time so we divided by the rate
okay that's the speed so by taking the
distance okay which is this guy here
divided by the rate which is this guy
here we were able to solve for the time
so another good formula to know distance
equals rate times time